[Music]  it's my first team choice so I'm excited  to be here and we're nominated so that's  pretty cool I'm Lee no how would you  feel if you won I think I already won by  being nominated but I think it would  just be a cherry on top of the ice cream  if I did do try I mean it's still so  crazy that that movie had the powerful  women in it but it did are you still  talking to Reese - Oprah - Mindy or you  guys keep it in time yes we actually  have a group chat which is really cool  so we all keep in contact if we're just  like a big happy family so I'm glad that  I have those women in my corner who's  the most active on the group chat who  most active on the group chat I would  say miss Ava I would say it was like she  like created the group chat and she's  the most active on it and who is the  most like right there with the memes and  the gifs who's very giffy I'm the gift  the gift Queen so I'm in charge all the  games  you